I'm easily frightened by zombies I still
dream of things that would evening maybe
because I'm so rich in protein and fat
and I was very very afraid of a chart so
jaws sealed it for me
zombies I don't have nightmares almost
ever but a recurrent nightmare I have is
being chased by a shark and then I get
out on the beach and I get spaced by his
uh please we change me upstairs of all
to a rooftop and there's a rooftop chase
with zombies creatures should be thought
of as real animals and you have to
design them with the Grace and the
cohesiveness of a real animal a lot of
people think when they're thinking about
creatures they think about accumulated a
series of trades that are scared bigger
teeth bigger fangs bigger laws a frown
but in reality when you look at a tiger
or a lion or a shark they can be pretty
serene or have an absence of expression
and they reveal their features the mouth
the jaws the claws when it's necessary
but if you observe a lion and repose
it's quite a majestic beautiful creature
to watch now if you watch a lion on top
of you about to eat your face that's not
fun or gracious or majestic is horrified
designing creatures should be done with
that in mind if you design creatures
with the purpose they serve in mind like
making them scary mobile creatures I
think that's a big mistake
when I became aware of the Wreckers I
very very early on as a kid I admired a
Hitchcock very much not only because he
was fat Catholic and repressed but
because he had a great sense of human
grammar within the structure of a genre
like suspense
I loved James Whale and I still loved
him to these day Terence Fisher a lot of
the horror directors they did Cronenberg
George Romero and you know it's just I
am a big fan
even before I'm a filmmaker so as a as a
fan you tried to study the directors
your life
being a director is doing a mixture of
things that are very very much many of
the time much of the time of opposites
you know you you are part a very
delicate soul you're a part a Salesman
too part feisty guy you're part a
politician it's a really complex craft
especially in today's world but at the
same time it's a craft that if you
decide to access just from practicing is
you can actually immediately with your
cell phone with an HD camera and start
practicing enough I think that that's
the difference between choosing to be a
director or being a director if you are
already a director it doesn't matter
where you're directly in HD or in a
small camera you you can practice
practice practice so tell stories and
tell stories trying to either create a
world or provoke an emotion or if the
best possible world both